for the millionth time body positivity
is not a movement about health so when
you bring health into it you are being
fat phobic the body positive movement
was created by fat black women in the
sixties to one create a safe space for
fat people
to address systemic fat phobia because
nine times out of ten fat people are not
treated like people in 95 percent of
situations beauty is not dictated by
your size so when you bring health into
a movement that is not about health ring
dang that's fat phobia so [ __ ] cut it
out she says
the fat acceptance movement the body
positivity movement is not about health
like ding ding ding you're right it's
not about health but it ought to be you
know we ought to be able to say that
it's not good if you're too skinny we
would call that anorexic and say you got
to beef up a little bit and if you're
extremely overweight then you know it's
not the end of the world you're going to
do what you're going to do but it might
be good to get into a healthier position